[Musique]
un accueil qui s'imposait après un an de
guerre en Ukraine une cérémonie
militaire pour marquer l'arrivée de la
présidente de la Commission européenne
le Canada et l'Europe deux alliés unis
par des intérêts communs de partenaires
historiques deux amis rapprochés plus
encore par des circonstances
extraordinaires Justin Trudeau n'allait
pas accueillir Ursula vanderleyen les
mains vides on va également déployer des
formateurs médicaux des Forces armées
canadiennes pour aider les forces
ukrainiennes à acquérir des compétences
en médecine de combat le Canada bonifie
et prolonge sa mission d'entraînement
pour les militaires Ukrainiens en
Pologne et investit 3 millions de
dollars pour contribuer au déminage
Ottawa envoie aussi des transformateurs
électriques pour aider l'Ukraine à
rebâtir son réseau endommagé par les
frappes russes
fait plus que sa part depuis le début du
conflit a pris soin de dire la
présidente mais il faut plus
comme des obus dont a cruellement besoin
l'armée ukrainienne au front il y a
l’armement mais aussi l'énergie l'Europe
cherche à se détourner des combustibles
russes mais difficile pour le Canada de
contribuer davantage ses capacités
d'exportation de pétrole et de gaz
naturel sont limités les deux leaders
regardent plus loin émis sur l'énergie
propre pour les années à venir un plan
d'action amélioré sur l'hydrogène entre
le Canada et l'Europe et l'Union
européenne
plage de batterie au lithium la volonté
de resserrer les liens transatlantiques
avec l'économie verte et les minéraux
critiques face à une autre adversaire
commun sur le champ de bataille
économique la Chine le Canada et
l'Europe doivent jouer dans le même
équipe
les chaînes vitales ne doivent pas être
contrôlées par les puissances
autocratiques
députés et sénateurs étaient venus
nombreux pour écouter le discours de la
leader européenne au commune mais Pierre
poillievre et plusieurs élus
conservateurs brillaient par leur
absence de quoi trancher avec l'appel à
l'unité d'Ursula vanderlayen nous allons
appuyer l'Ukraine aussi longtemps qu'il
ne faudra dit-elle
le Canada n'était qu'un prélude la
présidente de la Commission européenne
promettant le chemin des États-Unis le
point culminant de sa visite officielle
en Amérique du Nord le pays qui en a
fait le plus pour l'Europe du point de
vue militaire et énergétique depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine ici Louis
Blouin Radio-Canada